we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two David P so this
voicemail relates to a video I played
for you yesterday in which may be the
most delusional Trump supporter we've
ever encountered said that he's with
Trump because of family values and
integrity of character and so on and so
forth and we said family values and
Trump that doesn't seem to make any
sense this caller who called our our
voicemail number says we are not
understanding what Republicans mean by
Family Values take a listen to this yeah
I can't believe you don't already know
this when Republicans talk about Family
Values that means though I hate gays I
hate abortion
I hate birth control I hate women's
rights I hate marijuana legalization and
I'm going to put as many pot smokers in
jail as I can that's that's their Family
Values right there right I guess I just
misunderstood when when that Trump voter
said he's with Trump because of his
Family Values I guess I was thinking of
reasonable Family Values but if you go
by that here's the thing even if you go
by that Trump is lying I mean listen
Trump's been for woman's rights women's
rights when it comes to abortion for his
entire life until he started running for
president Trump is for contraception
yeah he's only even pretending in the
least believable possible way to have
changed his mind on those things but
maybe you're right maybe the caller is
absolutely right about this we've got a
great bonus show for you today we will
talk about another one of these
supposedly inspirational stories this
one's about a McDonald's employee who's
92 and still working I find the story to
be dystopian not an inspirational story
we will also talk about Prince Charles
looking at reducing the number of Royals
and what's behind it and what it would
mean and much more great bonus show
today hope to speak to you then